Wow festive good afternoon I am Olaf
please let me finish and I like warm
hugs
this is my associate spend we're going
door-to-door looking for family
traditions tell us yours and we'll
decide if it's special enough oh we made
candy canes together sugar you're
supposed to eat it eat my new nose why
would I do that
[Music]
happy merry holly jolly season's
greetings here I'm wondering what your
family does at that time of year love
and joy and peace under the tightest of
good cheer you have tradition things for
that time of year let the holidays begin
do we have any traditions Alfa
I'm sorry Anna it's my fault we don't
have a family tradition tradition on it
every scene we're going door-to-door
looking for family traditions we make
candy canes together
[Music]
sugar uh you cut down a tree and then
you dress its corpse with candles i
bringing of entering okay I'm Christmas
look another reindeer
[Music]
let's go find a tradition
[Music]
nothing like taking your calls up once
in a while you know any
whoa gross that went right through me
[Music]
you
you